hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll before
jumping into today's episode let me just
talk about some meta commentary the
state of the podcast as we all know this
is a new project for me we're all
learning what's going on I'm having fun
I hope that you're having fun but we're
still you know propagating the podcast
out there in different ways
I certainly appreciate any efforts that
you folks make to get the word out
through Twitter or recommending it to
your friends I tune reviews or make me
just as happy as any other podcaster
some of you might know that libsyn the
hosts that I use for the actual podcast
episodes has an automatic thing well
they will put the podcast on YouTube
it's just a still image it's not really
a video it's just a the mindscape banner
logo there but the audio is the same on
YouTube as you would get on the podcast
so for those of you listening to it if
for whatever reason you would like to
watch it on youtube go ahead there's no
video there they're probably never will
be any video I know people say video
would be better you know Joe Rogan does
video Joe Rogan also makes millions of
dollars off of his podcast and so far I
am putting money into it and not getting
any out maybe someday I will get some
out I would like to at least pay for the
microphones and so forth I don't know
what that would eventually mean maybe
just some kind of patreon page or
something like that that would be ideal
if it comes to ads then you know that's
fine because you can get money and I
like money but we'll have to see well
it's not going to be something that
happens right away for those of you who
are watching on YouTube already just so
you know it's also available on audio in
the usual ways on iTunes stitcher it
finally got onto Google Play Google Play
was having a problem with Lipson feeds
so you don't need to have your YouTube
open there you can just click on the
links that are in the description of
each video on YouTube it will take you
to the podcast website where you can
just listen to the audio or download it
on your apps on your phone whatever you
want there is even our subreddit a Sean
Carroll subreddit that you can check out
if you want to discuss further
the YouTube comments have been awesome
but you know a more centralized place to
go is on reddit where people are talking
about these things so I think that's all
that I wanted to say for the commentary
stuff so let's get into today's episode
the theme of which is that we don't know
everything as we go through life but we
still have to make choices we still have
to act in the world somehow but we live
in a situation of incomplete information
we don't know what's going to happen in
the future we also don't even know
everything about the world right now so
what we do is we attach probabilities to
things we say there's a certain chance
that something's going to happen
a credence is how much weight we put on
one possibility versus another and then
we act accordingly formalizing this idea
of placing probabilities on things and
then acting accordingly is called
betting and nowhere is the idea of
betting made more explicit and
formalized and in the game of poker
poker is one of my favorite games it's a
game of skill that has luck involved
because you don't know what the other
players have but you can make choices
and some of those choices you can win
there are people who make money over the
long term very regularly playing poker
those are called professional poker
players they really exist there's no
professional slot machine players
because there you're just losing money
overall but poker is a game of skill and
today's guests Liv Boeree
is a perfect person to talk to about
this stuff Liv was a physics major as an
undergraduate at the University of
Manchester and she was quite good at
that but she decided instead to add a
little spice of excitement to her life
by becoming a professional poker player
and she's done pretty well I can't say
it was a bad choice she's made almost
four million dollars in winnings at the
poker table and so we're gonna talk
about what you learn from being a poker
player what that helps you do in terms
of your everyday life making choices
about one thing to do or another in
conditions of incomplete information
where probabilities are central Liv is
also still remains interested in science
and is developing TV projects to help
popularize science she also has become
interested in altruism and charitable
giving within the umbrella of effective
altruism trying to use empirical data
to maximize our impact as charitable
givers she's the co-founder of an
organization called raising for
effective giving which funnels money to
organizations that have shown that they
really have gotten good bang for their
buck in terms of the charitable dollars
so we're going to talk about poker we're
going to out altruism we're also gonna
talk about how to think about the
existence of aliens whether or not
aliens exist out there in the world
turns out to be something that's at the
intersection of science and also
probability how do you reason about
something like that when you have so
little data so let's go
[Music]
libery welcome to the mindscape podcast
thank you very much
so now you are trained at least
undergraduate education wise as a
physicist astrophysicist now you are a
professional poker player correct so
just to set the stage I think for a lot
of people if you say professional poker
player they know exactly what that means
I bet a lot of people in the audience
are unclear that there are such a thing
as professional poker players is that
even legal
are you like in downstairs is it like
rounders are you getting in trouble what
is the situation what is your lifestyle
like how does this work being a
professional poker player so it depends
obviously from person to person there
different types of professional poker
players but I for the most part play a
type of poker called tournament poker
where everyone puts up an equal amount
of money and you exchange for that you
will get a certain amount of chips and
basically everyone keeps playing until
someone until everyone else has knocked
out and one person has all the chips and
wins either all the money or certain
certain sort of distribution of the
price ball like capitalism exactly yes a
very very aggressive zero-sum form of
capitalism and and yeah so I got into it
in in a very random way as you said I
studied physics I fully intended to
carry on in physics I loved it but at
the same time I had been in education
you know I was 21 I also had ambitions
of being a rock star I was very into
heavy metal and disturbing my neighbors
late at night playing guitar and so I
was like you know what I'm gonna take
the summer off after my graduation and
and start I need to make some money
somehow so I'm gonna apply for TV game
shows because I felt like that later as
a contestant as a contestant I always
liked playing games long story short I
learn how I learned to play poker on one
of these game shows and I loved the game
and I was like you know what I think I
want to take a few years and throw
myself into this game I think I have an
aptitude for it it seems like a lot of
fun I want to travel the world and get
some life experience still in the back
of my mind saying I'll come back to it
I'll come back to physics right once
we've made our pile yeah let's make some
money pay back my student debt etc
and now 10 years later still here the
dead has long since been easy yeah
exactly i if things well things just
turned out pretty well in in the poker
sense and yeah so like in terms of a
sort of lifestyle it's a lot of for me
at least traveling to different
tournaments so there's a big stop in
barcelona at every august or there's a
big stop in Vegas which I've just come
from the World Series and you all sort
of travel around to these you know it's
not the Pro Tour because anyone can play
them right but the professionals tend to
like that's their lifestyle going from
event to event and playing in these two
so literally anyone listening right now
as long as they have the right amount of
money can show up they the tournament
say Here I am
it's I want to play it's not like a golf
tournament or basketball yo anyone is
welcome and it's a meritocracy once
you're there exactly yes anyway anyone
can play it doesn't mean you necessarily
should play but if you want to and you
have the the money and the desire then
you absolutely can and I mean I think
that's what sort of obviously separates
poker a little bit from something like
golf because golf is you know the the
results of a golfer is very closely
correlated to their skill level whereas
with poker particularly over like a
small sample size of maybe 10 even 100
tournaments the the worst players could
be fastly outperforming the bet the
better the the best players and so to
say oh well we're only gonna let in the
you know the people who've had the best
results over the last six months that's
that's stupid and and people would just
get very annoyed with it because a first
of all everyone thinks they're the best
and that's why poker exists but B it
wouldn't actually be correlated to
necessarily being the best players
getting in and see the ones who are good
would like the money from the people who
are not good it's constant battle
between well I won't be playing against
the best I mean let's say I'm the best
but at the same time I don't want to
scare people off and and so yeah you
need the weaker players you you want to
be playing against and in my deal world
but it is a game of it's a combination
of luck and skill right I mean like
everything in life but it's not just
luck there's a certain element of
randomness you're dealt the cards but
then you played them in a certain way so
it's not like playing blackjack or craps
where there's really no way to win
without
kind of cheating yeah exactly I mean
with those games yet the the casino you
know it it's built it's big golden holes
and amazing rooms and spaces because
they have this small edge that over time
they make money from and they you know
the longer you play and s you know how
to count cards which again the casinos
will kick you out for for doing you
can't make money playing blackjack and
roulette
whereas poker because you're playing
against other people and the casino host
it basically because I think asinus
don't really want to host poker they're
not really making great money from it
basically just like a small percentage
of each pot but yeah with poker you're
playing against other people and so if
you are consistently making better
decisions than your opponents then you
are going to be making a profit in the
long run I do get the feeling though
that the casinos enjoy having poker
players around some of them are very
good at playing poker but then are
perfectly willing to blow it at the
baccarat is a very very correct
observation yeah I mean I've known many
many poker players who were some of the
best in the world and yet had no money
to their name because they were the
worst in the world at walking past the
roulette table it's just another game
did you're walking past it
yeah you just who's that and they know
that they should lose on average but
they just love it like that's you know
it's yeah I mean there's there's I think
to be a good poker player you have to
obviously have a willingness to you
cannot be a risk-averse human like you
have to be willing to gamble to take
risks to have those like hot in the
throat moments but at the same time you
need to be able to do that in an
intelligent moderated way and some
that's it certainly not the best players
you see around now but most of them
actually don't have what we call sort of
the degenerate gamblers speaking them as
much but there are still some who do
struggle with it and it's it's quite a
tragedy to see someone who's like worked
so hard at being so good at one
particular game right but then have this
sort of life we've got a life leak a
leak in the bottom of their pocket yeah
which is some other form of gambling but
I mean it makes for great stories though
it does and it's it also contributes to
this aura that the game has of being
slightly
reputable right yeah no matter how much
money and TV exposure and everything and
you still to this day do as you lewd to
hear stories of some of the world's best
players just disappearing like they're
hiding they come back oh they just lost
five million dollars over the weekend
you know and it's it it therefore must
be a very different kind of lifestyle
than maybe you thought you were signing
up for when you went to university as a
physics major yeah I mean like I've seen
this sort of I had some insights I mean
like you know have some insights into
like the world of you know at the top
chess players for example and it is for
the most part a very different sort of
social dynamic because the best chess
players like they really have to I mean
they just study and study and study and
study and I mean they're brilliant
obviously at what they do but I don't
know like many I think but I think poker
players have a little bit more of the
while sort of not free spirit but you
know what I mean like this this wildness
to them they you know there's this these
urges I guess that they want to fulfill
they they get thrills from many other
things as well as where as chess players
tend to you know they have to be so
laser focused on what they do but also
but sorry but just continue exactly in
their line the thing that you're doing
when you're playing poker is
fundamentally different than the thing
that you're doing when you're playing
chess when you're playing chess both
players see the board rights 100% when
you're playing poker you don't know what
the other person's cards are and so they
put out a big bet they go alright here
it is this is all your stack this is for
your tournament life you have a pretty
good hand but not the metaphysically
perfect and you need to I mean ideally
say well there's a certain chance that
they're bluffing there's a certain
chance that they're not and I'm just
gonna write risk it yeah exactly I mean
with like with chess you have all the
information there there is no hidden
information I mean sure you can't
directly see into the other person's
brain to see what specific strategies
but you usually have a pretty good idea
and there's not like a very definite
bits of information that you don't have
whereas poker yeah it's incomplete
and so that's why you have to think
probabilistically
and yeah so then it becomes sort of this
a largely a science of being able to
quantify these uncertainties that you
have like okay well what is the range of
hands that they could conceivably be
playing here okay it's from pocket twos
to a skiing like that and and what also
what is the but then I have the piece of
information that they they bet this
particular card but not this one and
they bet this size and and then on top
of that there's there's the even harder
to quantify things like oh the pulse in
their neck seems to be going really
really strongly here when I wouldn't
expect it to this is inconsistent with
the story they're telling with the with
the with their chips so you know how
what do I do with that like and so it's
it's this there's all these like little
bits of variables of information of some
of which are you're extremely confident
about and other than others you're
really not and you've got sort of
evaluate all of these somehow and put
them in together to go and come out to
one one answer that is most likely to be
the correct decision that you make I
don't know you know ed Witten the
physicist ed Witten the famous string
theorist I've heard yes yeah he is you
know he would probably win the poll of
you asked most theoretical physicist in
the world today who's the smartest
theoretical physics already talk yeah he
doesn't like poker because he says like
I don't know what the other person has
like in chess I could out thank
everybody but in poker you have to make
up these what heuristics basically
heuristics models right as the opponent
and of course the counter to that would
be the john von neumann helped invent
game theory cuz he went become a better
poker player literally right he was he
was playing poker that's it that i'm
surprised um but and then it doesn't
like it so much because i mean is still
ultimately a mathematical game it is but
there's also psychology so i'm sure one
of the classic questions you're asked is
what is the balance of yes doing math
versus doing psychology when you're
literally at the table so the answer to
that is it entirely depends but to throw
i hate throwing like probabilities out
there when there's it really does too
wildly depend I would say like ninety
percent and so if I say for example I
wanted to make you into the very best
poker player in the world I
want to sit with you and make sure that
you have put 90 percent of our effort
into making sure that you understand the
game theory the math right enough the
the actual like the the the building
blocks of the game so that your
strategies are built upon that because
it's ultimately a mathematical game then
on top of that if I can teach you some
of the like the the psychology and the
the harder to quantify parts you know
these like it's sort of I guess build
your intuitions ups so that you are able
to sort of Intuit from people's
behaviors what they're thinking but
that's just more really just a matter of
experience I think ultimately some
people are more inclined you know aren't
just better at reading people than
others naturally but I still think it's
ultimately a learnable skill and again
some of the best poker players still
find ways to almost like quantify their
uncertainty about these like very
psychological human characteristics yes
you'll have you'll know what the correct
you know I should be calling 40% at the
time according to game theory and then I
have a piece of evidence that suggests
that actually the opponent's bluffing
very like far ret more le than that well
how confident am I in that and then I
might waver the needle to say somewhere
down to 35% I'll call instead but it's
still something that you can quantify
yeah I once went to a movie premiere
with a bunch of people and one of the
people was Phil Laak the poker player
right things poker player goes himself a
time scientist a time scientist he's not
no we didn't talk about that but we're
like chit-chatting a whole bunch of us
in the lobby before the movie starts and
Phil suddenly says there's an 83% chance
that I'm gonna have to pee before the
movie ends so I should go to the
bathroom right now and I didn't know
whether or not that that sort of silly
precision of 83% was a joke or whether
he's just that good at estimating things
knowing Phil he is pretty good he does
like to think in terms of probabilities
but that degree of granularity I would
yeah so obviously there's math in the
sense of okay I need a heart to come
down only have one card there's some
elementary math what is the percentage
chance of heart
but there's also higher-level math in
particular the game theory situation
with sort of optimal strategies and
dominant strategies and exploitative
strategies do you study that as part of
your education training as a
professional poker player yeah ideally
you you want to sort of familiarize
yourself with so I mean well you're
lucky in this day and age there's there
are these solvers out there that you can
basically will run Monte Carlo
simulations in different you can like go
okay what should I do with Jack nine
suited on a ten seven four one suit
board you know of the same suit and you
know like this similar scenarios like
that put them into the solver let it run
for a few hours and it'll show you what
the game theory optimal strategies with
the range of hands you conceivably have
in that situation would be so there
would usually be like a percentage of
those hands that you would want to to
check raise because they're really good
for example because you know they're
they have a lot of equity but there's a
percentage that you would want to check
call because they're kind of in the
middle of the road and then there's a
percentage that you would then want to
Bluff because you need to balance out
your range you can't just check raise
with the strongest hands you need to
have some bluffs in there from so that
you you know so you can get called
you're you're you know you need to have
the the appearance of having a balanced
range of hands Plus and weekends when
you make an aggressive action and so
anyway you can literally find out what
is the you know as mathematically close
to the perfect game theory optimal
solution is now yeah and these different
scenarios and so the very best players
will sit and work with these these
solvers you can't use them in real-time
but you can go away and just study for
hours and sort of try to basically build
a mental model that emulates these game
theory optimal solutions and then once
you have these this this mental model of
game theory optimal then you can go out
there and play using this style as a
sort of as a base but then you were then
deviated from it as and when you come
across an opponent who is playing not in
a game theory optimal style because a
good way to think about it is like if
your and I were to play rock paper
scissor
mm-hmm and you don't know anything about
me what would you be the strategies the
best strategy that you would employ I
believe the best strategy is randomly do
1/3 1/3 1/3 exactly exactly you want to
perfectly randomize because you don't
have any information about me so in
response to that the best case that I
can do is to also randomize perfectly
because if I don't do anything on that
you're going to be exploiting you know
you'll be taking advantage of me so
that's like a Nash equilibrium basically
I'm sorry explain what that is for the
people out there in podcast land so a
Nash equilibrium is basically a state
strategy where it's unprofitable for
either competitor or any competitor it
can be multiple competitors as well like
more than two to deviate from that
strategy if you if you deviate from it
you're only going to be losing on on
average in the long so it's the
equilibrium where everyone is doing as
best they can as best they can and
breaking even in this in this situation
you're breaking even against each other
like if we both play on something
exactly yes
however if you found notice that I start
throwing rock I know every time yeah
should you continue playing better
Saturday exactly you wouldn't want it
you'd be stupid to carry on just playing
this perfect 33% randomize thing no
you'd want to start playing paper yeah
far more often or like a hundred percent
and so that is what you'd call then an
exploit you you exploit my bad play by
deviating from the previous game theory
optimal and so that same kind of thing
applies in poker you'll be playing you
you'll start off maybe ideally playing
this game theory optimal strategy and if
your opponent's equally good they'll
hopefully try and match that and you'll
be in the long run breaking even against
each other but because basically no
human in the world can play perfectly
game theory optimal there are these
rooms you you want to see over the
course of time you'll observe what these
mistakes are people are playing and so
you'll deviate and start exploiting
those I was I was highly amused to learn
that there were competitive
rock-paper-scissors leagues they do
because how not good at randomizing
right right and in fact this is a very
educational moment for me also the New
York Times
had an app where you could go and play
rock-paper-scissors against the app and
basically it had trained as a a I sort
of thing on millions of real-life human
being robbed a rock-paper-scissors
players and realized what the tendencies
were what the deviations from randomness
were and it would beat you and I went in
there it was small you know it was not
large but noticeable like you know like
when hands you could definitely tell the
or losing yeah yeah that knows my
experience but then what I realized was
like so I went in there cocky I'm like
yeah I know that how this is working I'm
gonna beat it and it destroyed me but so
then I realized I there was something
that I felt I should be doing like I
played Rock two times in a row I should
play scissors or something like that
right and I would tend to do that and I
was losing don't do these like same
thing in the row at many times yeah
that's right that's hard to do because
you don't realize how many times those
sequences come up randomly right but
what I realized was if I figured out
what my impulse was and real and and had
the strategy that the New York Times app
would probably play a dominant strategy
against my not tendency yeah then I
should play the one who would beat that
and suddenly I kicked attacks I really
so it's just a matter how many you know
well it's not the most exciting game in
the world right so you know dozens but
not hundreds of we can find but and
another thing that I along these lines I
remember the first time I learned about
in the realm of Nash equilibrium and
game theory the fact that in in games
like this mixed strategies will
generally be the dominant or the
equilibrium optimal strategies in other
words there's no one action you should
ever take every time in that situation
and it's perfectly obvious in
rock-paper-scissors it's also true in
poker if you have pocket aces you know
in some position the best possible
strategy is not to do the same thing
every time no matter what you have it's
almost always true there and then so you
have to if the strategy is to be one
thing ninety percent of the time and
something else ten percent of the time
it's really hard to ever do that ten for
something you know you're not doing the
best thing right well so
some of the again the top players have
started doing now because like everyone
knows that you need to be able to
basically be a perfect randomizing
machine to have these not only sort of
to remember what the these ratios you
need to have you know in certain
situations where you want to be bluffing
with say 10% of your hands and and and
betting for value with 90% how do you
randomize that well people have started
looking like watches like yours we've
taken it off but with the second hand
right old analog watches have become
popular again why because it's a really
good randomizer if you're if you go okay
you just use where the second hand is on
the clock face okay if it's between 0 &
4 if you want if you know you want to
check raise 25% the time is it between 0
and 15 oh yes it is ok this is a check
crazed situation if it's not okay I
checked cool do you do that um not as
much as I should I've done it I've done
it a few times but a I always forget my
watch how the players do it by actually
just like shuffling their chips all the
time because usually the chip will have
you know the word word written on it and
just where it lands you know yeah that's
that's a way and even if you're if this
is a thing people think all you need to
then keep this secret that you're doing
this know if your opponent know they're
playing gto against me okay it's I need
to just it's just an unsettling thing to
know basically yeah yeah but part of me
thinks that it's less important to
actually play the game theoretical
optimal strategy than to make your
opponent think you're playing it right
because they're not perfect optimizers
or randomizers either so if you're
supposed to do something two-thirds at
the time and something else one-third
right and your randomizer makes you do
the one-third of the time thing three
times in a row then I would definitely
do the other thing no matter what they
randomizer told me the next time because
I'm not actually in my opponent is not
building the correct model of me that is
true to an extent yes but at the same
time if your opponent is also then
playing this perfectly sort of
randomized in the right way style
their style will not be losing out to
the because they're playing this this
unexploited style then arguably you're
going to still been playing less
perfectly than they are and so in the
long run again it's always down you know
and in the long run you'll still be
playing less a less profitable style
than them or sorry I let a more
exploitable star than them but when it
comes to poker at a table with six or
ten people we don't know the game
theoretical optimal not always poker has
not been solved and in fact as far as I
know artificial intelligence cannot win
at a ten hand ten player table you know
there's been the AI that successfully be
humans heads up one on one when I want
yet but I I don't even know if anyone's
trying to do the three-person and higher
game because I mean the game tree just
gets ridiculous yeah the tree and yet
before humans do it exactly yeah we're
really really good at UM building these
sort of heuristics these these I don't
know why we're so good at it but it's
where we're able to sort of condense
this down into these rules of thumb
though work out really well I mean I
think it kind of makes sense that that's
that is what we're good at
right the Thinking Fast and Slow Daniel
Kahneman would explain you know we don't
think in terms of rational logical
choices generally we think in terms of
heuristics we do in terms of rules of
thumb and we're really good at coming up
with models of the world that are pretty
good yes get us by yeah yeah yeah I mean
do you use Bayesian analysis or
something like that very much why don't
you explain what Bayesian analysis is
sure so base analysis it Bayesian
analysis is basically updating our model
of the world based upon new information
incorporating new evidence based on sort
of the weight the strength of this
evidence whether it's proving or
disproving our beliefs and then you know
when we see when we see that thing
happen we'll go ok well this means I
should change my mind by this amount
it's like shifts the needle you know if
you think all all trees are green or
leaves a green you'll go around but then
if you see you'll go around assuming
that but then if you see a tree with
purple leaves
well now that's evidence to suggest
that's not so true so you now shift
towards okay maybe not all trees a green
etc and you there's a way you can
actually model that
automatically using Bayes theorem do I
do it mathematically in-game absolutely
not I don't have likelihood ratios shown
in my head no I mean ultimately our
brains of Bayesian machines right that's
what we're doing naturally without
really realizing it and I mean at least
to me it seems like it's a sort of
fundamental law of not a physical law
but it is you know it's a would you call
it a psychological law it is some kind
of law of the world we live in right
bayes's theorem yeah a theorem it's you
know it's the correct way to update your
your model of the world I think yeah I
think it seems like it it's a rational
way to behave yeah
and so my impression is this is my
amateur poker players way of thinking
about it you can tell me what that makes
sense you know you sit down at the table
and you more or less assume everyone is
the same in some way and then as you see
how they play you your model of each
individual player becomes more
sophisticated yes
so we have ways in poker of sort of
describing that right there are tight
players and lose players and aggressive
players and and so forth and maybe then
you say well of this person is tight
before the flop and then they become
loose afterward and is that more or less
what's going through your mind yeah I
mean not that I would ever advocate
stereotyping people at all but when you
sit down at a poker table like I just
played the World Series of Poker Main
Event for example where it's generally
against a lot of amateur players who you
know pony up the $10,000 once a year and
it's you know it's the best woman of the
year it's really good it was profitable
for you right oh yeah what's up pretty
well this time um and and so when you
first sit down I will immediately look
around the table and create base
literally above first impressions of how
someone looks you know literally their
gender their their age the way they're
sitting in their chair the clothes
they're wearing the way they look at me
you know their their appearance of
confidence or not confidence and so I'll
immediately create a sort of some kind
of stereotype a prior prior exactly a
prior but then in an ideal world I'll
still just try and you know not let that
influence my play too much just a little
bit but as soon as you
start getting real information after
like 20-30 hands well now I've seen okay
this person hasn't played a single hand
over 30 hands did I think they would
type before hand actually yes and does
the evidence continue to confirm that
yes it does okay so I can shift the
needle a little bit more to strengthen
that belief but if I notice actually the
person who you know like the old guy who
seemed kind of conservative and timid
has played every single hand and he's a
great raising and re raising everyone
okay better update but it's time to
update this is very strong evidence
let's shift the needle more towards he's
an aggressive player and so yeah you
you'll sort of start building these
models of people and and by the end of
the day if you've spin at the same table
we now you've got probably multiple
hundreds of hands of where you've seen a
lot of information of people's
tendencies with increasing degrees of
nuance and so you'll build up a very
accurate mental model of players over
given a period of time so do you take
this way of thinking mixed strategies
game theory optimal etc bayes's theorem
and updating your priors do you extend
it from poker to the rest of your life
has being a professional poker player
changed how you go about buying a house
or getting a boyfriend
anything where to go for dinner yeah I
would say so in terms of just like
thinking about things in terms of
probabilities and uncertainties you know
beforehand I was very black and white in
my thinking I will either happen or it
won't or you know I certainly wasn't
comfortable with any kind of granularity
and now I'll sort of look at something
and be like okay do I think you know am
I gonna make it in time for this podcast
judging by the LA traffic
yeah the probabilities gun down and I'll
you know estimate at least mentally and
hopefully I'll try and communicate it to
people as well what I think the
likelihood is in in terms of a
percentage and 30% to be there on time
that kind of thing and I mean in terms
of picking boyfriends well yeah I mean
egor picked a poker player
it's hard money when you're playing on
the poker circuit not to also you know
have a significant other who's sharing
the same lifestyle but yeah funny story
Igor and I actually what you go ask me
now about half a year ago randomly he
said what do you think the likelihood is
that will we'll still be together in
three years time because we were like
talking about moving cities and should
we buy a house and he said well what do
you think the likelihood is we'll
actually be together in three years time
I was like good question that is sorry
that's a question that would only be
asked by number one a poker player and
number two someone who is pretty secure
in the relationship yeah I well yes well
yeah that's that's a reasonable thing to
assume and luckily our numbers came out
fairly similarly I think it was like 92
and 94 percent or something like that
excellent yes there's a non-linearity
there like getting the wrong answer
could change the profits lutely yeah but
at the same time it's it's really useful
to know even if you don't end up being
honest with each other the fact that it
asks you to reflect on that right and
you come away and think oh actually the
number 60 percent but I found myself the
word ninety percent coming up my mouth
well if nothing else has information for
yourself that's right right like oh
there's there's something not quite
right here
fortunately like I did genuinely I was
like no I think it's it's definitely
over 90 percent it's definitely under
100 percent you know the stuff can still
happen therefore and luckily we were
pretty much lined for ya so it
definitely I found it but has bled into
my thinking in all sorts of ways and in
general you just you just become more
strategic I mean I don't think that's a
bad thing I know that people sometimes
when people I saw what you do and I
particularly if I'm in some kind of
negotiation they're like oh you're a
poker player well I don't believe
anything you say
come on drinking poker is all about
massive crazy puffs right not about
strategic thinking exactly yeah it's
like no it's about it's about choosing
when to bluff you're at Tomb actually
minimizing your risk when you Bluff like
I I've found that blood bluffing is
stressful like it can be very fun when
you get away with it but it's really not
fun when you get a court
oh yeah and having you know when you
poker players know what it's like to get
your Bluffs court be caught in a lie
it's a
it's embarrassing and being actually
just financially hurts and it and it can
knock your confidence and so on and so
way from the table I don't like lying
isn't really very fun like I get I get
to scratch that itch at a table and it
just creates complications and and you
know and this is a really really really
good reason for it
it's tend to try and avoid it and it is
embarrassing even at the poker table but
it shouldn't be right I mean you're just
playing the game theoretical optimal
strategy why yes yes Bluff called
yeah no I that's that's definitely a
thing I try to you know any anyone I'm
teaching poker I say no like the first
time you get caught in a bluff turn
those cards over and slam them down and
I have a big smile on your face and be
proud of yourself that's a place it's a
big part of the game and you have to get
used to that sort of getting your
fingers caught in the cookie jobs we
don't ever get caught then you're not
probably not doing it often enough so
yeah there's like there's so many like
different facets of the game that sort
of bleed over into life I mean it just
the emotional control part of it yep
okay you you learn to get used to bad
luck very fast because I mean you play
10,000 hands in a week you're gonna have
one percenters you know where you should
win the hand 99% of the time but you
don't have multiple of those happens and
they really sting yeah but you know
probabilities they compound over time
and if there's many many instances of
bad luck things that could happen then
eventually one of those will happen to
you and so if you saw remember that I
find you you get less emotionally
attached yeah I mean what do you said
about the granularity of probabilities I
think is very true I mean I have this
idea that almost everyone thinks there
are only three probabilities for
anything it's either zero percent 100
percent or 50 50 yeah yeah the idea of
something being 70/30 is just really
hard for human beings to latch onto and
maybe this is that those heuristics that
we grew up with in the you know in the
wild and the belt of Africa like you
better make a decision right away under
under conditions of stress and and you
don't get to do things over and over
again but so do you you would really say
that your experience as a poker player
has give
you a better ability to correctly handle
those 70/30 situations yeah I think so I
think you you know I mean you're
familiar with the term scope and
sensitivity in terms of you humans we
evolved in sort of tribes probably up to
150 or so people and so beyond that
numbers weren't that useful groans we
didn't have to count much beyond that
yeah and you know the classic example of
oh there's there's a thousand birds
dying in oil dying from an oil spill
somewhere you'll feel some degree of
sadness about that if I say there's a
million birds dying from oil you don't
feel a thousand times sadder you feel
probably a little bit sadder but about a
thousand times and so we have this like
our brains aren't intuitively equipped
to to think accurately around really
large numbers or all really really small
numbers we just work on this little a
little macroscopic level that's in our
everyday lives and so that and I would
say that's very into in realms of
probabilities that sorts us out between
the sort of 30% errs and the 70% is but
beyond that things just it feel really
oh it's it happens 10 percent of the
time all that's an ever yeah that's a
never and OH
85 percent time I pretty much always and
I don't know like I think on the most
part you don't have we don't have an
intuitive understanding of what actually
like a 5% feels like or a 7% or a 10
person but poker you play enough you
will like I find my emotions genuinely
correlate with like when I turn the
cards off on the flop for you know we
get a big all in and I'm a no I'm a 12
percent underdog it so I am yeah I only
got a 12 percent chance to win well I'm
just not gonna get excited I'm like okay
yeah and or if I have a 1 percent chance
of winning then my emotions are even
less you know I just don't feel anything
I mean I'm just annoyed that I got got
it in so bad and but if it's a coin flip
my heart will genuinely be racing
because I'm like wow I will win this 50%
of the time and who knows what's going
to happen and so yeah you you sort of
become well calibrated to what these
actually these these probabilities mean
because we've just seen we've seen these
situations so many times over
does that therefore apply to the
every day world I mean yeah like if I'm
someone says all your I don't know 10%
to to make a flight I think well if I
can figure out that I'm roughly 10% to
make a flight then I will be I you know
I would be extremely pleasantly
surprised if I didn't make it whereas I
think but at the same time I don't think
I'm that well calibrated as I am in
poker you're tired yeah it's hard
so just to change gears a little bit I
was pleased to see that you had an
article in Fox recently you went back to
your sort of astrophysics training and
it you know is a story about the
application of probabilities to
interesting questions about the nature
of the universe so why don't you fill us
in on what that was yeah so recently
some of this the researchers at the
future of humanity Institute and in
Oxford published a paper on called
dissolving the Fermi paradox I just
mentioned most viewers know what the
Fermi paradox is that's not imagine that
let's tell him what it ok Fermi paradox
is basically what Enrico Fermi back in
when was it nineteen fifties yeah he he
was very radioactive yeah but yeah
basically he you know he looked up he
was like wait there seemed to be
billions if not trillions of stars out
there and we know that the universe is
somewhere around 14 billion years old if
there's so many possible sites for life
why are we not at least you know we've
been releasing radio waves now for a few
decades
yeah like relatively easily surely we
should be least hearing or picking up
trace signals from other words or else
seeing aliens all the time like the
universe is so old it must be at least a
few other thousand civilizations out
there they've got a big head start on us
but so where where is everybody and so
that's the like famous Fermi paradox
like the the contradiction between the
size and age of the universe and the
lack of observed alien life and so this
paradox is seemingly only gotten
stronger with time as you know we've
become more spacefaring and we've
discovered more and more exoplanets and
you know it seems like there
you know universe is even sort of more
more capable of hosting life than we
imagine a lot of places out there right
and and yet and yet we've still seen
nothing and we've been really looking
hard and anyway so this paper that they
published use uses the Drake Equation
which was sort of this equation that
sort of is the best way we could try and
estimate the number of intelligent
civilizations within the Milky Way and
it does it's a novel form of analysis on
it that hadn't been really done before
and the answers that sort of came out
the back of that is that we are
somewhere around 75% to be the only
intelligent civilization within the
galaxy and some around a coin-flip about
50/50 to be the only intelligent
civilization in the entire observable
universe which is pretty pretty
astonishing stuff right counterintuitive
to many people extremely
counterintuitive agreed also quite
disappointing because I'd love that to
be some aliens out there I mean this
from curiosity standpoint but yeah
nonetheless pretty groundbreaking claim
and so the article was sort of
discussing how they came to that claim
what the actual process is that they did
they did the the methods of analysis and
but then I wanted to make a sort of
larger point from that which is okay
well we don't know for certain that this
is actually the case but let's assume
that it is based upon our current best
state of knowledge it seems like we're
if nothing else life is extremely
intelligent life is extremely rare in
the universe what does that mean
philosophically speaking for for us if
we really are the only intelligent
civilization out there and may well be
for the rest of the universe's future
what what does that mean you know what
should we do anything with that
information should we change any of the
behaviors that we're currently
exhibiting and the trajectories that we
seem to be putting ourselves onto and I
think yes I think we it speaks that we
have a greater responsibility right to
not blow ourselves up I do want to get
into that but first I want to dig into
this probability stuff because the Drake
Equation is something that has been you
know batted around
and nauseam right like people not
talking about the Drake Equation and so
for the for the two of you out there in
podcast land who have not heard about it
the Drake Equation is a way of
estimating the number of intelligent
civilizations by saying well how many
planets are there times what's the
fraction of planets on which life
develops times what's the fraction of
which the life becomes intelligent it's
that you know different ways of breaking
it down but as far as I can tell there's
quite two things in the new paper that
are kind of interesting one is they take
seriously the idea of rather than
finding just our best fit number for the
fraction of times life comes into
existence and then becomes multicellular
they say what's the uncertainty or what
is the probability distribution so
tracing those probabilities a bit more
seriously and secondly it is a matter of
being good Bayesian zand updating our
priors right I mean they're they're not
saying just based on the laws of physics
we're probably the only intelligent
civilization in the galaxy they're
saying based on the fact that we haven't
seen it yet right that in some sense
Fermi was right it would have been very
very easy to run into another
civilization if they were out there
there we haven't seen them they don't
seem to be out there and therefore from
that we draw the conclusion that
probably the simplest of explanations
are just not there maybe it's just way
more unlikely that intelligent
civilizations exist and continue to
exist than we thought it might have been
right exactly the the the fact that we
haven't found any evidence of aliens is
evidence unto itself right and should be
incorporated into sort of the Bayesian
model that we have of the situation with
able to pinpoint one of the factors and
say this is probably the tiny one in
terms of which one has the the smallest
probabilities it doesn't usually forms
yeah well the one that has the biggest
number of range of uncertainty on it is
a fraction of planets that develop life
okay which makes perfect sense what do
we know about that exactly like we we
still haven't really figured out how
life started on on earth the process of
abiogenesis is just really not well
understood yet and so the difficulty
that we've had with the Drake Equation
is that before we're sort of plugging in
numbers like the rate of stellar stellar
Genisys within you know the number of
stars that developed per year.we
that's a that's an astronomical number
we have a reasonably accurate we exactly
we have data for that but then something
like the fraction of planets at
developed life it could literally be the
the uncertainties they have like 200
orders of magnitude its that yeah and
and the thing is is that because like
that's those any number between that is
actually completely plausible by saying
oh well yeah but let's ignore the fringe
parts of it that's making a statement
that's making a claim of knowledge that
we can't make you know say oh well it's
probably somewhere in the middle know
like it's as can see you know the
probability distribution is is like
fat-tailed all the way down and so to
cut these off is is is just doing bad
math basically yeah I'm glad the paper
came out because I've run into great
resistance
I've always felt basically this like we
don't know how likely it is the life is
going to exist the other obvious
bottleneck is multicellular life which I
again we don't know how that exists
maybe I tend to think that once we get
multi cellular life intelligence is
probably not far behind
yes but both the existence of life
itself and multicellularity seem like
very mysterious maybe the chances are
just 10 to the minus 100 right and
people say there are so many planets out
there and like there's no number n such
that I cannot find another number that
multiplies it and gives us a small tiny
tiny tiny no exactly yeah um I mean
there's sort of the idea of like there's
this great filter where there's some
kind of insurmountable barrier that
exists somewhere in the in the chain of
evolution that for whatever reason most
planets can't get passed right and for
some reason earth managed to get past it
like I hate to even like hazard a guess
at where it is but like intuitively know
the intuitions really applied to those
it feels to me that it's somewhere in
the step from singer singular progress
why prokaryotic - to eukaryotic life
somewhere around there but again that's
just yesterday are just multicellularity
but just the idea of having a nuclear
exactly having it having a nucleus
within a cell that seems probably more
important yeah
something somewhere around that and
there's some other work the future
humanity Institute are doing right now
on the similar analysis but looking at
the transitionary time the rates it
takes to go from each step to each step
and it just seems quite likely that the
reason why the earth what the reason why
life isn't everywhere is because it just
it's it just takes such a long time for
it to actually get to the stage where
intelligent civilizations then actually
spring up right the the plant you know
we made it on earth five six of the way
through yes life span in about seven
hundred and fifty million years came
into being relatively very weak right so
then it sat around in this boring
nothing state and suddenly there was
this explosion where evolution goes you
know kick-started faster and and and and
things interesting things started
appearing but that wasn't basically
until five six of the way through of
Earth's lifespan had it just been a
little bit longer we would not have
existed because earth sort of been
gobbled up by the Sun so and so that's a
reasonably plausible explanation as to
as to why you know it life is incredibly
rare I suspect that's the right
explanation my other favorite one is
that there are plenty of civilizations
they all become highly advanced they
upload their consciousness into
computers and then they become bored and
they don't go space traveling anymore
yes that's a good on also the a
starvation hypothesis you know that one
I don't know that one um you'll be
better to explain the exact reason why
but because computation is expensive in
in higher temperatures in and Ratt you
would expect a rational civilization
that would want to maximize the number
of computations it can do okay have a
time so it makes sense to them to
hibernate or east of eight okay until
the general temperature of the universe
you know and feel far far in the future
in the the ambient temperature the
universe is much lower and therefore
it's much cheaper and you can I think of
something like ten to the 30 more
computations a second you could achieve
or something like that
I can't remember exactly it's under
Sandburg has a very fun paper on it
I've never heard of that one I'd like
the audacity of it I don't believe it no
I doubt so I'll tell you why I don't
believe it because I'm the one the
temperature of the universe goes down
nice that's fair but also the free
energy of the universe goes the energy
we have available to run our computation
goes down so I presume someone smarter
than me has actually done the
calculation and said it's still better
to wait but there's clearly oh yeah I'm
pretty sure he fights us that in but I
not first enough to explain why
nonetheless again it was one that fell
into it it was very fun but intuitively
I'm like mad probably because it only
takes one
you know plucky counter example right
only why civilization has to not buy
into that yeah but it does remind me of
John Wheeler used to say when he mixed
cream into coffee he always felt sad
because he was increasing the entropy of
the universe irretrievably but you do
bring up this question of what does it
mean what do we what at what
implications so what if we are the only
civilization only intelligent life forms
it makes you think you know for better
for worse but making you think is good
why are we here what is the point so and
you actually been thinking about things
like this right yeah I mean I I mean I
was just having a having conversation
with my partner Igor about sort of moral
moral realism I know that you're very
much a non moral moral realist entirely
human constructivist yes yes and I'm of
the same same mindset but that said it
if you want to sort of if nothing else
maintain optionality earth's going
extinct is definitely going against that
like now the options of have disappeared
to zero and that seems it definitely
appears like there is a very real risk
that we can go extinct by even 2100 and
by real risk estimate somewhere between
anywhere between like 2 and 20% I'm a
mile constructivist but the morals I
construct do say that human extinction
would be big will be bad yes yes I don't
need an objective story to tell myself
about it right exactly and and yeah it
just seems like it would be a terribly
big shame if you know all this these
little pockets of low entropy have
managed to appear us you know
basically going against the second law
of thermodynamics to a degree oh oh we
actually going against the second
nothing goes against the second law of
thermodynamics so how this is what I've
never wrapped my head around how do
pockets of low entropy so successfully
exists well it's it's actually an
outgrowth of the second law of
thermodynamics because if we think about
it if it weren't what would it mean to
not have the second law of
thermodynamics right what would it mean
is that we were already in thermal
equilibrium right we were already at a
maximal entropy state right once you say
the early universe started with low
entropy that's all you need to say then
entropy increases and that's the second
the only way out of that is to say you
were already in high entropy and then
there would never be any life there'd
never be any complex structures there'd
never be anything like I say we are not
creating pockets of low entropy we are
leeching off of the fact that the early
universe had an extraordinarily low
entropy we're increasing the entropy of
the universe willy-nilly right there's a
separate question related but separate
which is why are we complicated why are
there complex structures in the universe
and that's something that it makes sense
that complexity develops along the way
from low entropy to high entropy but the
details of how it actually happens is an
ongoing fun research problem and life is
certainly just an example of exactly
that right and and so yeah I think it
would be arguably a tragedy on a
universal scale in terms of just lost
utility and lost potential and and lost
optionality if you even from just the
expect you looking for an expected value
standpoint if we were to go extinct even
if it's a 0.01 percent chance they're
still going to be 10 to the I don't know
how many possible lives you know and
possibly very happy lives in the future
I have met people who argue that the
human race should go extinct that would
be a moral good that the rest of the
planet would be better off would right
oh there there assume their extreme
negative utilitarians no no that says
that the utility goes to the plants and
the animals not to us we're a net
negative they claim I don't believe them
I'm just saying in the other what's
their main argument as to why we are a
net negative just because we create
suffering upon
yeah we're highly distorting the
ecosystem
you know the so much of the biomass is
devoted to keeping us happy and it's not
a natural state and right define natural
well yes I don't defend this right
laying it out there no I mean it's
definitely an interesting viewpoint to
discuss and I have to say into it my
intuitions are very you know I grew up
in nature I like I love nature maaan
anything and nothing upsets me more than
seeing like images of the rainforest you
know this millions and millions of years
old beautiful unbelievably complex
rainforest you know a tree being cut
down into planks of wood something
that's on so unbelievably complex and
sustains this intricate framework of of
an ecosystem around it all the insects
and animals of the fungi and everything
that grows off it and relies upon it is
is reduced to very planks of wood that
people then put you know yeah you know
that's put down into this complicated
ecological sorry economic system out of
this complex and I think they're two
very different things
complex ecological systems so like
intuitively it seems like a huge tragedy
that we are doing that nonetheless I
also think intuitively is a huge
strategy that this you know human
consciousness there does seem I don't
know inherently special but there's
definitely something inherently unique
that is not we're not seeing elsewhere
in the natural world as much and for
that to go out and the thing is is if we
go extinct well chances are probably all
the other most of the other big animals
will go extinct too as well I just
wanted on the record that we were having
this conversation at a concrete table
not a rainforest wood table legs
yeah yeah yeah we varied morally correct
in our living room
but it doesn't we probably don't really
think that it effects that calculation
whether or not we're the only
civilization I mean maybe it makes it
more poignant right right but we still
don't want human beings to go extinct
even if there's a hundred billion others
out there I mean there are plenty of
people who think that there are 100
million others out there and they're
waiting for us to grow up a little bit
right right I have my suspicions that
that's crazy also but it is at least one
of the options on the table yeah I
it's definitely I mean igloo con you
can't rule anything out that's the thing
when we're dealing with something of
such uncertainty like this and certainly
humanity has a lot of growing up to do
but that said there's a lot of beauty
and goodness in the things that we are
doing and it would be nice if we given
the opportunity to try and grow up and
you have put your money where your mouth
is quite literally becoming interested
not only in these philosophical
questions but the applied questions of
how to be better people how to make the
world a better place and in the
effective altruism movement in
particular and you don't just talk it
but you like started an organization
yeah so I felt people would effective
altruism even is yeah so effective
altruism is basically the combining the
head and the heart when it comes to
philanthropy and doing good you know we
all the vast majority of us we want to
do good in the world you know if we see
someone suffering we will try and help
them you know you see someone passed out
in the street the actual human instinct
is to usually go and check on them or a
dog yelping or whatever it is someone's
screaming fire you know we're all for
the most part naturally altruistic and
that's a great thing but at the same
time there will also be you know
different ways there'll be some ways
which are more effective at getting a
certain certain problem alleviated and
so effective altruism is basically
applying science to philanthropy to to
altruism doing doing good as effectively
and efficiently as possible
and so I remember like hearing about
this that you know there you know I
wanted to give money to example
environmental charities but I often
first felt lost I was like well where do
I start what's you know I want I'm
concerned about climate change I'm
concerned about biodiversity loss etc
except all these different things which
how do I weigh these off against each
other when I give my money to one
charity that means I'm actively not
giving my money to another you know we
we only have limited resources ever to
give and so it's imperative that we do
as much research we can or at least
consult people who have done their
research to figure out where we can get
have them biggest positive impact with
whatever we get whether it's not just
money as well time if you choose to work
for a charity you want to make sure that
it's the the actions that you are taking
in your line of work are achieving the
most good because you won't get those
hours back time is also a scarce
resource and so after hearing all these
arguments I was like well this makes a
lot of sense and a team of full-time
effective altruists they suggested we'll
look we think poker players will get
this they you know they're very used to
thinking in numbers about uncomfortable
things they comfortable with the idea of
sort of thinking about expected value
and uncertainty very um quite a variance
quantifying things and they're also you
know poker players I think are willing
to despite sort of the impression you
know that we're all like dark degenerate
money gamblers actually you know like I
think a lot of poker players are aware
of sort of a unique position that they
have in terms of we have sort of time
and we can make good money and it would
be nice to contribute to society in some
way and so we decided to start this
organization called raising for
effective giving reg - charity - org
raising raise it exactly turn on their
chips thing you and I have many
arguments about who came up with the
name yeah um and yeah so four of us
poker players started it alongside these
the Swiss effective altruists and we
yeah we were incorrectly originally we
were encouraging poker players to give
two percent of their profits sorry two
percent of their net
no gross winnings every quarter and some
people sort of continue on that model
others just sort of because pokers are
very all-or-nothing kind of game often
you'll have a big win followed by months
of losing months yeah and so generally
people just tend to donate when they
have a big win as a percentage and yeah
it's been extraordinarily well received
I had no idea that poker players would
like get it as much as they did and it's
raised over six million dollars now and
we we so the charities are specifically
you they use giveWell who you might know
give all dog Wells usually where I go
yeah they're they're fantastic and throw
in in terms of like human suffering
reduction they are the go-to in terms of
you want to find out how you can help
human lives right now as best as
possible so we use their tops we
recommended charities which are almost
always against against malaria
foundation and sort of something
deworming and direct poverty alleviation
with like give directly and and and
that's because like the costs to save a
human life like your hate it
unfortunately is just many hundreds of
times cheaper will not make like around
a hundred times cheaper in the
developing world than it is here say in
the US or in the UK you know in in the
u.s. there are you know the government
more up to spend up to around a million
dollars to save a life
on if you look at sort of cross health
care and that kind of thing and yet you
can demonstrate demonstratively save a
life in some parts of sub-saharan Africa
for around seven thousand dollars so
like that's a huge huge difference and
even if you think that an American life
is worth more than someone say from
Malawi do you really think that they're
worth a hundred x would you like would
you press that button to say I will kill
a hundred Malawians
to save one random Americ and it's not
talking about an American you know like
to someone someone random from America
you in a part you've never been to would
you really say they're worth a hundred
you know a hundred mothers are worth one
mother here no and so yeah it's about
this sort of idea unfortunately you you
do you have to like put a price effect
it's not putting a price on a human life
but it's it's about saying my actions I
I can help someone with the the money
that I give and so I want to help as
many people as possible with that and so
yeah so we've got some we've got the
best Charities in human suffering
alleviation the best ones in animal
suffering alleviation by best I mean
most cost effective and the animal ones
almost always a to do with that anti
anti factory farming yeah um just
because it's pretty tragic what's going
on out there and it's very very cheap
just to save
very sentient animals from the life of
misery and then we also have neglected
research areas specifically ones looking
into things like global catastrophic
risk so yeah like people looking into
risk from bioterrorism because even if
it's a tiny chance exactly that's even
though it's a point one percent chance
you know if you factor that over the 100
billion or so lives that are going to
exist over the next century that's
roughly what the number is even over the
next century that's a lot of people I
mean it seems kind of obvious that we
should try to be efficient and spend our
charitable giving as effectively as
possible but there has been pushed back
right I mean some people don't like it I
mean personally I'll confess I'm not a
till eteri and I think it's hard to be a
consistent utilitarian but still I take
the effective effective altruism to be a
good nudge in the right direction right
I mean we're I certainly do value the
things we see right in front of our eyes
more than the things we know are going
on out there in the world and this is an
excellent reminder that there's there's
ways to make a huge impact elsewhere in
the world that might not be quite as
obvious to us exactly it's not just it's
it's it's taking you know it's not
saying that if you you know react you
know a to something immediately
happening in front of you that that's
not a good way of doing good of course
it's good like it's there and and a big
part of when you do good you're trying
to do something else Rishta can help
it's fine to also feel good about it you
know I think people go oh you know you
you shouldn't you shouldn't have any
positive emotions that come out of it or
you shouldn't be doing in that way I
think that's silly like know like you
want to do whatever continues to
motivate you yeah that doesn't gain from
absolutely and and you know and so it's
about like I said it's about balancing
not just the head but also the heart
your heart is a big part of any kind of
charity giving and so on and I think
it's it's a mistake to try and remove
that out of it but at the same time we
have to be aware that just purely acting
emotionally when we know that we have
these big biases in terms of like we
randomly will sort of value people who
happen to live in the same town as from
someone who lives in a town 100 miles
away yeah even though we don't know
either of them just because
that's just the way human intuitions are
sort of built and that can then be a
mistake in terms of our sort of narrow
resources that we have to allocate I
mean maybe from what we said earlier
there'd be a good charity that could
give everyone free poker lessons because
it would help them think in
probabilistic ways about the world uh I
I wouldn't I wouldn't specifically say
that but yeah I mean like there is a
there is a charity who I mean there are
at least a sort of 501 3 C but who train
young people in Applied rationality yes
quantifying things it which is basically
applied poker doesn't at all talk about
poker but they training promising young
people who are looking to get into sort
of research politics you name it the the
art of rationality which is incredibly
important because these are going to be
the future leaders and you know we I
think we want leaders who are aware of
human biases and aren't afraid to think
in sort of scientific terms and you know
to give them the tools to understand
their own emotions and so on and and
therefore be better better equipped
decision makers and I think that's an
incredibly valuable thing and that's and
that's one these kind of organizations
that are looking into teaching
rationality classes in schools I think
these are incredibly promising area to
donate to because you know they can
create a city there's definitely a huge
lack in our current education system
like how many kids are taught to you
know think through their feelings for
example or yeah like it oh it's okay to
be uncertain let's see if we can
estimate our probabilities like these
basic rationality tools that you and I
take for granted like we only take we
only know them because we learnt them as
adults either through poker or through
another means but imagine if you were
just taught these these basic things or
like learning to think through the
counterfactuals something like that I
wish I learned that when I was 10 there
was save me so much time or yeah just
like looking up the probabilities of I
used to be a huge hypochondriac the
amount of worrying time I've spent you
knowing always my headache a brain tumor
if I just learnt to like do a bit of
Bayesian updating I would have saved me
a lot of misery
/ you know my in my late teens and so
yeah it's it's I think it's a big shame
that these these areas are neglected
well that I think it's a perfect place
to end because you basically
encapsulated at the mission statement of
this podcast trying to get people to
think a little bit more rationally a
little bit more cognizant leave their
biases and a little bit thinking in
different ways and they usually do so
libery thanks so much for coming on the
pike
[Music]
you
[Music]